hey this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm this is a soda
saga level 125 walkthrough with some
commentary in the beginning we can just
kind of play straightforward there's not
much we can do with the small space so
we just want to you know make specials
when they're there and just try to set
them off pretty quickly so that we can
move down the board fish will go after
the the bottles so they're good but when
you really need to try to get stripes
and stuff like that and this is kind of
an interesting thing here you know this
color bomb that's cool to get that set
up but it's not easy really to do much
with it at this point but I got a fish
and you see that's only gonna set off
like five fish when we match that
together so it's not as effective as
it'll be later hopefully later we'll be
able to set up some bigger ones but we
still want to do that that'll take a
layer off each one you know five of the
bottles so that's that's better than
nothing for sure and so as things start
to open up a little bit you'll see that
we want to pop a couple bottles and then
as to the as they pop the soda will fill
up and then at that point our fish will
be a little bit more effective and we
can hopefully get a cascade that'll go
up through the soda to help us out it's
sort of like a lot of the other levels
you know you're not gonna be able to
like hunt all the bottles down but
there's only if let's see there's a
yellow orange
blue and green so we only have four
colors on the board so we can get pretty
impressive cascades if we can open that
everything up so you can see where a
couple the bottles are here now it you
know it could be better to go down the
side in some ways but you don't really
have a choice you just sort of have to
go with what the board gives you and
striped striped now will be pretty good
with the color bomb we're down to eleven
moves so you know we're gonna have to
move pretty quick but if we can get a
cascade going then that will hopefully
clear out the rest for us so looking for
a way to bust through the middle but I
need to pick up a couple bottles - so
fishes like a fish would be good a fish
combo would be better
and you can see even by just a little
bit of more space the Cascade you know
produced a color ball in the drop where
that one happened as much in the
beginning so that's why that's so
important
so number down the eight moves we still
have six more bottles but we might be
able to still might be able to do it
just gonna have to try to plan out as
best we can
if we get to a point where we're not
making any more progress then we can go
ahead and fire that color bomb off to
damage things a little bit but we're not
there yet I mean we still have six moves
so making this striped here is a little
bit better than the rats because it'll
hit the orange bottle and hit the yellow
when it goes off I'll make the rats
first and that also opens that up and
then you can see like I said what the
cascades get a lot better so here we
only have four moves so we can't really
plan to match the two color balls
together that will only make one layer
as it is so here I think maybe using
this one to hit the green will be good
because it'll take out a bottle open up
another bottle and we'll still have the
color bomb at the top that we can
hopefully make a bigger combo with so
we'll go ahead and do that
get all the green out of the way that
might lead to some other specials too
yeah so you can see like right from the
beginning once those bottles start to
pop the Cascade gets a lot better so we
have one bottle here to our left and we
have one on the green on the right side
that you can see so we want to get we
definitely want to get a cascade that's
gonna do some major damage on the I can
see here that we have the we can maybe
make another one if we match the orange
up top
yeah if we move them if we measure this
orange on top we can set up another
color bomb it doesn't do a whole lot to
get towards that bottle on the right but
but it could help out a lot in the
Cascade now with our last move we're
gonna have to match the yellow to pop
that bottle and then just hope we get a
really good cascade here
there one came out and there's like yeah
so see how that that that's how that
works obviously sometimes you'll get it
a little bit faster and you won't have
to rely on the last move but that's the
basic strategy it's a tough one so hang
in there because you know you'll
definitely have problems on some tries
where you won't be able to get that
opened up but if you take your time and
plan things out you should be able to
find the right setups so you know just
real quick just break you way down the
middle or on the side whatever comes up
in the beginning and then start to look
for ways to get a spot for the starter
to come up and then set up a cascade so
that the cassette will take out the rest
of the blocks as its bringing the four
different colors up you get a lot of
specials you saw that in the video so
hope this helps please like it and share
it subscribe to our channel so you'll
see our new videos when they come out we
make new ones all the time so check back
soon thanks